because you've never been you've never
been in the alts with me bro
well
oh [__] yeah yeah [__] I forgot
on the outs about no I think after you
and your girlfriend broke up I think
there was a moment where you thought I
was gonna try to make a move I think
and I remember you being a little bit
strange to me I'll tell you what I think
out of all the comics that would have
made a mood that you had the better
chance the best chance to get in maybe
that's what it was thank you I saw and I
did not make a move you would never make
a move not a chance brother I could name
you who did
I'm not getting it oh dude
let me guess were they were they black
or white
white white the whites do that [__] the
blacks don't do that man they don't
they're loyal bro yeah yeah man I don't
know yeah dude I would never have uh try
to slide in your ex are you guys are you
still living with your ex-girlfriend
no she moved off no yeah I didn't no she
she moved a couple of blocks away was it
sad when she moved out kinda
yeah because the house is so dirty now
oh really when you're living with a girl
yeah
your house is clean it's like its own
filter like a filtering system yeah like
oysters have that right right right
right but now it's like there's cat
vomit all over the place and the other
day they found maggots yeah dude no yeah
how many of them
one maggot no they found a hundreds oh
you know what it was it was like what I
do you know what I've been doing this is
so [__] sad I know it is but you know
when the girls lived up because I had
Jewels live there too and the girls up
there you know we would put out the cat
food wet food and after the cats were
done they would wash it me I just leave
out more bowls of cat food right and
then all of a sudden Jules was cleaning
my house and then she was like she saw
one of the and had been there for a
month
and there was just maggots in it oh yeah
so
um that's the sad part but it's all you
know you know in the beginning it's
lonely it really is because when you're
living with somebody for 10 years wow
and then all the life is sucked out of
the house she took the dogs too
yeah so like the first couple of months
it was like you'd wake up it was silent
um you know what I mean it was just
silent in my house and it it was like I
don't know how I made it through it man
I was really sad about it but then like
when I started bringing girls over and
then eating the vajans man oh wow down
there huh hello I'll take the specs off
for that
yeah hey let me start hooking up right
because you know I haven't done that for
a long time but that's kind of sad
though isn't it like there's some it
gets kind of sad just some gal comes
over and you you know and you hook up
and then she did she now are these women
are these women sleeping overnight are
these women going home one of them spent
the night it was okay so there's one
girl that I was seeing and like this is
maybe seven months ago and I was like oh
this is I like this girl a lot and then
other the blue she goes I met someone
younger by no and then I I looked them
up down younger than an Asian I know it
was a baby oh yeah you're getting a baby
he's eight months old yeah yes no um
this dude it hurt my feelings but this
dude look like
Brandon Lee bro who's Brandon Lee
I don't know man
no he was Bruce Lee's
son Bruce Lee's son the crowd he died oh
yeah he died got shot I remember that
yeah he was the first one to do that you
know what I mean oh wow he was handsome
handsome dude this dude was
he looked this her so she goes I met
someone younger I looked him but that's
what he looks like oh man and then you
see photos of them like at pool parties
and he's ripped no yeah so I was like oh
you're more together
then you know you're
body styles no I wouldn't say I wouldn't
use the term ripped probably
yeah I mean but what else about him no
but no what I'm saying though dude is
like just just said that I'm fat I don't
think you're fat at all
I think you but I'm the opposite of
ripped
I wouldn't see I would say you're I
wouldn't say ripped I would say you're
ripe conjoined or conjoined
yeah or joint I would say you're there's
two people in one body like assignment
like a Siamese twin thing I think we
could carve one off of you
that's me it did we get carved a little
yeah yeah I got some way dude can I be
honest with you Doctor yeah I haven't
seen you in a while you gained a little
bit too dude yeah
yeah you know what I mean and you got a
weird tan huh I do I love it
and healthy look healthy thank you
anyway so she started she goes I met
someone and it broke my heart and then
I'm like but now
I I met somebody you did
yeah man what what's up we're at you met
her online in here dude no you better
than the DMS remember when I saw you in
that movie you were just swiping people
were sending you wieners and uh breasts
and everything oh we were doing that
movie yeah no but I met this girl after
that okay yeah I met this girl I don't
want because it's new but it's like um
she was the first person that I kind of
want I'm like I kind of like I like her
you know aside from the girl that
betrayed me with the Brandon Lee you
know what I mean but um yeah I like this
new one you know she's uh
yeah she said something horse and you
know what dude bro let me just be honest
with you yeah
I [__] I [__] oh man I love wholesome
you do yeah I love church going
when they make sweaters what do you call
that
um when they're knitting
uh no a crochet crochet knitting
whatever I mean I like it when they have
they're like I've never seen Good Fellas
yeah right oh you can show them that it
blows their mind yeah yeah I never seen
The Departed yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah or
it's like they only this girl that I'm
seeing she only likes um Taylor Swift oh
yeah you know what I mean so then you
can open her mind up to like her good
music too you know yeah yeah yeah yeah I
mean like this is good music right here
I mean the Clash or whatever but I like
wholesome dude she goes to church wow
twice every Sunday really yeah what um
ethnicity like what church ethnicity is
she
what do you mean like what uh
I've never heard church ethnicity you
know uh denomination sorry
oh I see
I don't know the one with the cross oh
yeah yeah it has to do with the cross it
has nothing to do with other things yeah
I'm like an alien or whatever Protestant
yeah yeah yeah it's it's one of those
mega churches so it's like one of those
born-again you know how they do the
Harvest Crusade yeah in like a huge
Stadium
Jesus
that's the one I'm from
they have that in Oklahoma or whatever
yeah
that's a good shirt yeah
I have a resentment towards you I just
realized
yeah yeah yes sir what is it about you
think
and this is not a lie I swear to God I
swear to God on my life
okay so you know it's real right I don't
know but yeah I'm listening what do you
mean
yeah okay okay whatever yeah I believe
three times okay
on hinge when I was on it and two times
on Raya I matched with a girl
and in the direct message they said yo I
don't want to hurt your feelings but
um I'm not really I didn't match with
you because I wanted to hook I I want to
hook up with Theo can you set me up damn
and bro
you didn't set me up
how hard would that have been I made
that birthday video for you
dude
oh [__] never looked at it that way yeah
you think so I already have been when
you know your boys out here yeah looking
for love
oh [__] my bad okay look at the Lord's
lost and found out here lost you know
what so you just told me like I was
selfish about it huh yeah yeah so I
could have been like yo I know you were
you're so hot and I was excited when you
matched with me yeah because I thought
you liked you know I mean the way I
looked yeah and my comedy but you know
you think I'm disgusting but yeah here's
my boy's number because I just talked to
him and he wants to link up you think
that should have happened I think it
would have been the move I think because
here's what I'm saying they say if you
give it you give it away you know
you give it away the more people you
give it away to the more it comes back
you know what dude maybe you're right
you know I looked at it in a selfish way
then but you have to admit dude that
that hurts your feeling you would that
hurt your feelings
I think it probably at some point in my
life it would have now I don't think it
would have I've had I've had buddies
steal a girl that I liked and I I think
it yeah made me mad but then I think
like well if they're together then I'm
not supposed to be with that girl oh
dude you know you're looking in a
spiritual way to like everything happens
for a reason I think you are dude I also
put an air in a girl's shampoo one time
who broke up with me when I was in
college so
I say
I get it I get it so yeah I mean so I
guess those ladies because I've been
I've been scolding them online you know
on podcasts yeah hey lady if you whoever
you are you [__] you [__] and all that
stuff damn really yeah I do I get
resentful dude you have a lot of
resentment towards women do you think
honestly or no
here's what I'm resentful about dude
girls are you I hate their girls that
back in the day like I'm talking about
20 years ago I hit on you're like no but
now they want to link up yeah you know
what I mean now they want to now they
want to link up now now that you're the
top dumpling they want to [__] get in
the sauce huh yeah I'm one of the top I
mean in terms of dominance dude yeah I'm
in the bowl yeah yeah I mean I mean I
made it into the bowl dude there's like
eight dumplings in there you know now
that you're the big now that you're the
boss Bond me they wanna yeah they wanna
get a bite out of here yeah yeah but
it's like now they're like you know
wanting to but it's like [__] you yeah
you know what I mean but it's like well
I have yeah you know what dude and
what's great about being how old are you
me I'm 43.
the greatest
I'm 52 now dude he just turned 52. yeah
thanks man I'll take that bug
that's not from your apartment is that
some of the things that you have in
there is it no you don't leave those in
here man we just got this place I didn't
bring that I'm gonna say you just told
me your place got shut I didn't bring it
okay well I don't bring bugs around bro
that's [__] cray-cray one of your
stories was at your places I know but
it's not like they're like you know
being like hey let me hitch a ride well
I just one just flew off of you dude
that's the only reason I'm asking me
yeah anyway you seem like a great guy go
on yeah I just want to let you know at
52 though
[__] it like that sucks dude
it's just not that important anymore
yeah do you understand what I'm saying
oh yeah man I've like he used to be
number one dude but were you ever were
you ever honestly
were you ever were you ever any good at
sex honestly like were you ever bro
that's so insulting dude no but honestly
I'm great okay then maybe I'm gonna say
something dude
I have two forums yeah slow form and
long form
okay do you understand what I mean by
that man
all right let me think slow form and
long form yeah yeah okay
so sometimes I go short
oh yeah I go quick oh yeah so that
involves rabbit sewing machine style
yeah yeah
right yeah and then I do long struggs
oh
you know oh yeah and that I could do an
hour on that yeah it's like a manatee
swimming oh like a small Manatee
like a manatee
oh whatever yeah whatever dude bro who
wants to a big huge wiener that's all
cumbersome yeah yeah
yeah you know you have to have a buddy
hold it while you tie your shoes yeah I
don't want all like I don't like
checking in my bags at the airport dude
I bring it on yeah you know that's what
I do but I have those forms and it's
like
um but that's back in the day do you
enjoy it though do you enjoy sex as much
as you used to you think
no but I could take I I can go without
it yeah you know like when I was in my
20s I would like stay up all night
hitting on a girl like you know you see
a girl at a bar what do you mean hitting
on a girl you mean masturbating at home
or what do you really mean because I was
I'd be at the house yeah no I mean when
you know like if you were out like when
you're in your early days of stand up
right oh yeah in the early days you met
a girl on the road and you they were
like on the fans I would like stay hang
out with them till four in the morning
but now it's like I would never do that
yeah like if I was like if a girl walked
in right now
and this is the truth she goes hey so
next door I'm at a hotel when you come
over you know let's [__] and I'd be like
how far is it yeah next door I go I
would go
let's do it right here wow look at me
right here like in front of you like
let's save them up I'm not moving for it
right would you move forward uh let me
think to Next Door yeah I'd probably pop
over there you know all right maybe that
was a extreme example right but you're
saying like uh Encino you're not going
far out of here yeah I'm not gonna go to
NC now yeah I'm not gonna yeah you're
not gonna get out a map or something
yeah